إنها هجمات مروعة مثل تلك التي وقعت على
محطة قطار أوكرانية العام الماضي، والتي
ورد أنها أدت إلى
محاكمة أولى ضد روسيا في
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية،
حيث إن استهداف
البنية التحتية المدنية مثل هذا
المبنى السكني وموقف السيارات في مدينة
هاركيف يعد جريمة حرب بموجب القانون
الدولي.  القانون
تقول روسيا إنها تضرب أهدافًا عسكرية فقط
وتصر روسيا أيضًا على أنها لا تخطف
أطفالًا أوكرانيين مثل هؤلاء الذين تم إجلاؤهم
من شرق أوكرانيا التي مزقتها الحرب والذين
يظهرون في معسكر صيفي في شبه جزيرة القرم،
لكن أحدث التقارير تشير إلى أن
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية من المقرر أن
تحاكم روسيا على هذا الأمر.
تقول أوكرانيا أيضًا إن آلاف الأطفال محتجزون،
بعضهم منفصلون عن آبائهم الأحياء
ويتم تلقينهم
الدعاية الروسية، ثم يتم تبني الكثير منهم من قبل
عائلات روسية، وقد سُرقت
أوكرانيا فعليًا من قبل الدولة
[موسيقى]
ولكن داخل روسيا يتم تصوير الفضيحة
كمهمة إنسانية
[موسيقى]
المفوضة الوطنية لحقوق الطفل،
شخص يُدعى ماريا ليفوفا بيلوفا،
يناقش مع الرئيس بوتين
مشاركتهم الشخصية،
هل تبنيت طفلاً من ماريوبول
بنفسك؟ يسأل بوتين على شاشة التلفزيون الحكومي
نعم، إنها تستجيب بفضلك،
لكن بوتين ومعاونيه لديهم
مخاوف أكثر إلحاحًا بكثير من أي محاكمة نهائية
ليس أقلها المعارضة الشعبية المتزايدة،
إن لم يكن للحرب في أوكرانيا نفسها، فعلى
الأقل لكيفية خوضها [
موسيقى]
مثل هؤلاء النساء من منطقة موسكو اللاتي
يدافعن عن رجالهن الذين أرسلوا لمحاربة
أبنائهن وأزواجهن الذين تم تدريبهم على
استخدام المدفعية المتحدث  تقول ولكن تم
إرسالها إلى الخطوط الأمامية واستخدامها كجنود
عاصفة بدلاً من ذلك مثل لامب في
المذبحة، فهي تشتكي من
أن هذا النوع من الادعاء
بارتكاب مخالفات ضد الروس في هذه الحرب
وليس الأوكرانيين هو الأمر الذي قد
يكون الكرملين أكثر حساسية
تجاهه.